ground news is combating divisiveness in
media ground is a news comparison
platform that helps you see multiple
perspectives for any news story so you
can be more of a well-rounded news
reader download the free app at
ground.news
pacman welcome to the show everybody we
have a bunch of different covid news to
go over and so many different things
glad you're with us going to be a very
very full week um to start with
we are potentially just minutes hours
maybe a day from full fda approval for
the pfizer covid19 vaccine this is
important not only
from the standpoint of medical but also
because of how this may or may not
impact anti-vaxx individuals who have
been saying
as soon as there's full approval not
emergency use i will go and get myself
vaccinated and i've expressed skepticism
that all of the people saying that are
actually going to do it but we'll get to
that in a moment there's a new report
from the new york times which tells us
that the fda is hoping to approve the
pfizer bio end tech vaccine that's the
two dose regimen relevant because we're
already talking about a third dose the
two dose regimen of that vaccine full
approval expected today
if there's a delay maybe an additional
day or two so this timeline is on the
one hand it's later than many people had
hoped there's been a lot of why is this
taking as long as it's taking it's also
sooner than some of the least optimistic
timelines which we're looking at you
know later in the fall or at least into
september
i believe that as far as those
anti-vaxxed people who have been saying
once it's fully approved i will go and
get vaccinated i think that for a
significant portion of them it was just
a talking point it was just something
that they came up with to say to make
themselves seem rational to make
themselves appear as though it's not
just unhinged anti-vaxxerism it's once
it's approved i will go and get
vaccinated some of them probably will
but many will just come up with a new
talking point for example if they want
to they'll move the goal posts too well
it's approved but it was a very
political approval
and it was rushed and influenced by the
biden administration so we can't trust
the full approval i would have gone and
gotten the vaccine if it had been a fair
and and reliable approval but it was
clearly a rushed approval no evidence of
that but the reality is some of them are
going to come up with something new now
the other piece of this the other reason
this is important
is that there have been many
organizations schools employers
governments etc that have been thinking
about
do we require vaccination for our
customers for our employees for students
coming back to campus some have already
put in place some of those requirements
but others have hesitated because after
all the vaccine is approved under
emergency use they would feel more
comfortable requiring a vaccine
once it is fully approved by the fda so
that's the other reality the
requirements and the mandates are
likely to increase significantly once
this vaccine is fully approved which
again should be later today or
potentially tomorrow
some people say
they are against mandating a vaccine
that's only approved for emergency use
and so
when we have full approval we're
expecting to also see a number of
additional requirements and mandates and
my guess is
that the people in the anti-vaxx
contingent
who have been saying
the problem now is it's not fully
approved are going to shift to focusing
on what they will say are authority
authoritarian and dictatorial vaccine
requirements once it is fully approved
and the expectation is there's going to
be a lot of them there are some
hospitals and universities that are
expected to mandate vaccination once the
full approval hits the pentagon said
earlier this month that they are
planning to make covet vaccines
mandatory for the roughly 1.3 million
active duty troops no later than the
middle of next month but even sooner if
the fda grants that full approval which
we're now expecting any moment
now
i mentioned that this is approval of a
two-dose regimen you might be saying
well david hold on last week you
mentioned now there's a recommendation
for a third shot at the eight-month mark
but the approval is only for two shots
that's exactly right um that is the
biden administration announced you
should at the eight month mark start
getting yourself a third dose
uh the the approval right now that's
been submitted by pfizer which was
submitted months ago is for a two dose
regimen so the expectation is once this
is approved on the two-dose regimen the
um pfizer will immediately submit to the
fda for expedited approval of that third
booster shot
um and then we'll see how long that
takes so the bottom line here is
when we looked at what the reasons why
those who didn't want the vaccine didn't
want the vaccine about a third said i
will get it if and only if it receives a
full fda approval um that's going to
happen i suspect not a full third of
those who are against the vaccine are
going to go and get it once it's
approved i think it will have an impact
how big it will be i don't know now one
bit of good news recently by the way
after a really long period of declines
in daily vaccination in the u.s and then
very slow ascent
we are now back to
three consecutive days with one million
doses per day with roughly about 575
000 people each day being newly
receiving one dose uh that's very good
news 200 million americans have now
received at least one dose of the
vaccine and in terms of what would work
to better incentivize people to go and
get vaccinated remember that when joe
biden encouraged and new york city
announced a hundred bucks if you go and
get yourself vaccinated the hundred
bucks didn't really seem to be very
influential to people and there was a
poll done and the most effective
hypothetical requirement requirement was
if you needed a vaccine to fly
41 of anti-vaxxers said they would go
and get themselves vaccinated that seems
to be a really big deal
uh and then as we're going to talk about
a little bit later on in the program i
suspect
that if you made copays 50
instead of 20 bucks like imagine you
have insurance where your copayment is
20
or maybe in the emergency room maybe in
the er you know it's 200 300
if you make it 50 coinsurance if you're
not vaccinated meaning if you're not
vaccinated and you need to go to the
hospital for covid you pay 50 no more
copay i think a ton of these people
would go and get themselves vaccinated
it's not clear anything like that is on
the horizon uh but needless to say i
think it's something that would very
much work
uh this next story
you know i i feel sort of extra sad
about this only because we've been
covering it from the beginning
uh anti-vaccine
pro-trump
wing radio host phil valentine
who had been in the hospital with kovid
for some time now
has died
and we started to wonder if things were
taking a turn for the worst some time
ago because we were hearing from his
family he's not exactly turning the
corner
and phil valentine has now died
we covered this from the very beginning
there's a rolling stone article laying
it out
which explains a few days after phil
valentine announced he had tested
positive for covet 19 on july 11th the
conservative talk show host wrote on
facebook he was doing my patriotic duty
for natural herd immunity sort of
suggesting the way to get through this
is for people to get sick and recover
and develop herd immunity
this was a pretty big radio host he had
a national show on a hundred stations
for 12 years
he openly questioned vaccines on his
show
he mocked the vaccination campaign with
a song vaxman parodying the beatles
taxman
he said i am certainly not getting the
vaccine now
he said on july 14th
saying i have full immunity on the basis
of his positive covid diagnosis
he is now dead at 61.
um and as we had been following his
condition worsened steadily since being
diagnosed
he was in the hospital a full two weeks
and then placed on a ventilator on july
30th his brother said he was being
transferred to an ecmo machine which is
now we're talking not just ventilation
we're talking a machine that does the
work of the heart and lungs
phil valentine wrote on facebook on july
13th you need to have a plan in case you
get covered make sure you get your
vitamin d3 level checked and have a
doctor on speed dial listen to this who
will write you a prescription for
ivermectin
ivermectin is a drug
used to treat livestock heifers horses
mares etc
for worms and this is what some
have been advocating for you've seen it
on fox news you've seen it elsewhere
um
phil valentine's saying if you're at
high risk of dying from covid i still
strongly suggest you consider the
vaccine
just make sure you're prepared if you
decide against the vaccine i'm not gonna
go on and on and on talking about all
the different things that phil valentine
said but needless to say
he is now dead from coronavirus now
um
we heard from uh
republican senator marsha blackburn
republican senator marshall blackburn
tweeted about this and she said phil
valentine was a visionary for the
conservative movement
and he made an enormous impact on the
lives of many tennesseans my deepest
condolences and prayers are with phil's
wife susan
and his family
may they be comforted and surrounded by
love during this difficult time
you know i would really respect senator
marsha blackburn moore or at all because
i my respect level for her is zero right
now
i would respect her if she used this as
an opportunity to say
get vaccinated this is really serious
phil was 61 and as far as we know
healthy although i'm not totally sure
and he went out of his way for a while
to say no horse dewormer instead of
vaccines and he's dead now
uh she didn't do that she didn't even
refer to the irresponsible nature of his
anti-vaxx campaign now if we have to
find anything here that maybe we could
say is there any silver lining
phil valentine did become pro-vaccine in
his final days and he started
encouraging people around him and
messages getting out through the radio
station through his brother saying he
now says go and get yourself vaccinated
it is actually possible again this is
it's a bad situation but if we can find
something in it it's possible
that
he will save some lives by virtue of
becoming pro-vaccine and talking about
it to a crowd that would be
disproportionately vaccine skeptical
right-wingers his audience
once he was very sick it didn't save him
and he still promoted the horse dewormer
ivor mechtin really dangerous weaponized
stuff
but maybe
maybe he will actually be responsible
for some lives saved by virtue of the
fact that he lost his own life
statistically
because he did not go and get himself
vaccinated some people get vaccinated
and die but very few
in all likelihood being vaccinated would
have saved his life
now he is dead maybe his followers will
follow his most recent advice which is
go and get yourself vaccinated it's it
it's really reminiscent of the jonestown
jim jones temple stuff like where he's
talking about
you know uh uh follow him and if i told
you to drink cyanide-laced kool-aid
would you
and eventually he gave the cyanide laced
cool i mean the ivermectin stuff is
essentially that at this point will you
on my say-so do you trust me enough that
you will take the heart dewormer which
you might have to get from a
veterinarian although there are some
medical doctors that are actually making
it easy for people to get it's crazy
what's going on and a little bit later
we'll talk about what's happening in
mississippi
it's a dystopian coveted hellscape in
mississippi that is getting to or even
surpassing what is happening in florida
mississippi and alabama increasingly the
coveted hellholes
of the united states all of that coming
up make sure to let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at
dpakman
and by the way we are now only five and
a half million youtube views from one
billion youtube views when we get to
that billion we're going to do a huge
membership special you can be notified
by getting on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com but what a number one
billion views coming up really really
soon
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back ground news is
one of the first things i would use to
get my head in the game
and prepare myself for the interview
because ground news is a news source
comparison platform that lets you
compare how outlets from the left right
and center are reporting on a story it
makes it easy to see the nuances of how
sources with differing political biases
are covering a story and it also shows
you your news blind spots stories that
your side of the political spectrum
may not have covered ground news can
help you build a well-crafted argument
for debating people you disagree with or
ground news can help you discover
something new about your own perspective
challenging your own strongly held views
on political issues be the most informed
person in the room download the free
ground news app today by going to ground
dot news slash pacman
all right we had a bunch of interesting
stuff happen over the weekend i want to
start with a rally that took place in
coleman alabama this is a relevant rally
for two or three different reasons
number one this is sort of the start of
the 2022
election it's it seems to be getting
going this early mo brooks is running in
alabama donald trump flew in it was an
all-day rally and donald trump showing
up there in the midst of bad weather and
chaos and lies and delusions in support
of mo brooks also relevant was this
rally because of all the people who of
course delusionally believed that donald
trump was going to be reinstated as
president during august this is likely
to be donald trump's last public
appearance in august unless some other
rally gets scheduled for this last week
or ten days uh eight days that's left of
august and there was the belief among
some and i
i mean obviously this is ridiculous but
there was the belief among some that at
this rally donald trump was going to be
reinstated as president one such reason
why some believe that was that ceo of my
pillow mike lindell who i interviewed a
couple weeks ago
was at this rally and why that would
make anyone think there's going to be a
reinstatement like it none of it makes
sense i'm telling you the reasons why
people who don't know anything thought
maybe trump would be reinstated i'll cut
to the chase he was not but let's get
into some of these clips from this rally
it's a very
repetitive speech donald trump was very
confused and dishonest and we're going
to look at a number of different moments
but the most notable moment
and we're going to dive into this a
little bit later
is that donald trump was booed by his
own sycophantic followers when he
casually said hey guys the vaccine is
good and trump immediately having to
backtrack and say no it's okay it's okay
you've got your freedoms take a listen
to this three days less than nine months
and it's great and you know what i
believe totally in your freedoms i do
agree you gotta do what you have to do
but
i recommend taking the vaccines i did it
it's good take the vaccines but
you got no that's okay that's all right
and then the cheering starts freedoms
but i happen to take the vaccine
if it doesn't work you'll be the first
to know okay
that is really something i mean that is
sort of like when you train
a protection dog
to be so aggressive
that it even starts being dangerous to
the owner the owner has to get rid of
the dog because the dog meant to protect
him is too it's too aggressive it's too
dangerous
i think this is the first time that a
rally crowd of trump's
actually booed him i think they boo when
he gets them to boost someone else when
he says something about hillary or biden
or whatever
but i can't remember another time where
they actually booed donald trump
a lot of the stuff during the rally was
kind of the the typical stuff
donald trump claiming that the election
was stolen and that very soon you're
going to see the evidence coming out
we've been waiting for months i mean
will any of us still be alive when that
evidence comes out take a listen
one of the first acts that biden did
after mitch mcconnell said we must get
back to work we have to get our country
going we have to approve him as the
president
even though the evidence was staggering
you'll see the evidence starting to come
out it's already come out far beyond
what we need by the way far far far
beyond what we need and yet it hasn't
seemed to work
to put trump back in the office because
this is all a grift
we have to get back to our country and
running our country mitch mcconnell and
the first thing that biden did was sign
17 of the worst executive orders in the
history of our country those executive
orders actually were pretty good in that
they undid a lot of the damage that
donald trump did
trump then you know as usual on covid he
just seems confused he weighed in on the
delta variant and he talked about how
he's shaking hands with everybody and
hopefully it doesn't cause an outbreak
you know he doesn't know he didn't stop
the virus you know
they say oh he gets wonderful martinez
to get good marks he's done a terrible
job including on vaccinations including
on everything else and now the virus is
back
the virus is back i'm shaking hands with
everybody backstage i say well i don't
know this is a good thing or bad
you'll read about it in three or four
days maybe hopefully not
so he seems to acknowledge that
sometimes when he does these big events
and he's hanging out with people and
shaking hands
it causes spread and we i mean listen we
know it happened herman cain at least in
theory
got sick at a trump rally and
subsequently died we don't know that for
sure but the timing of it certainly
suggests that just always very confused
at a certain point during this event
trump shifted over into what we might
call foreign policy now
he you might hear this and say david
that's not really foreign policy what i
mean is he mentioned foreign countries
and when it comes to trump that's as
close to foreign policy as we're ever
going to get listen to this can't have
weakness in the white house they have to
respect your president when i was
president
we only had strength remember the 59
shots we took at syria
now remember those 59 shots at syria
that's the bombing of the runway
that he let russia know about ahead of
time which was cleared
and then reopened within 24 hours that's
the and i'm i'm not an advocate of
bombing i'm just saying even trump
projecting strength on that it was
pretty pathetic
59 missiles every single one of them hit
their target from 700 miles away
and i was sitting with president xi of
china you remember having chocolate cake
at mar-a-lago was wonderful cake
and when i said to him what we had just
done the missiles were launched
he looked at me and he goes
repeat
i didn't know he spoke english actually
he said repeat i said what did you just
say repeat
so he spoke a little more english than i
thought because he never said hello but
he said repeat so of course we don't
know whether trump is saying she said
repeat the bombing or repeat what you
said it's a completely incoherent story
as are most of these and then speaking
of foreign policy maybe one of the
strangest moments of the speech donald
trump claimed that a five-year-old was
advising him on military issues that's
weird but
i asked the child
so what would you do after describing
would you leave the military until
everything's out including the civilians
and
all of that incredible military
equipment
or would you have the military go out
first
sir i'd leave the military in
he was five
he said i'd leave the military in
get everything out first i said thank
you very much but they didn't want me
all right so there it is a five-year-old
kid knew exactly what it is that trump
should be doing uh there it is and then
um maybe the most sort of despicable
moments were when donald trump started
praising and shouting out complete and
total lunatics like marjorie taylor
greene who we'll talk about a little bit
later
and later mike pillow also known as mike
lindell let's listen first to him
talking about how great marjorie taylor
green is one of my favorite people
she's so smart
i hope she's around i hope she's around
she is an incredible woman
she's a brilliant woman doesn't get
credit for it but we all know about that
stuff
marjorie taylor green
where is she
can you imagine
she's great
she is great she's a warrior
she's a warrior everything i said about
georgia is true audrey right yeah
and that's really what it's about she
placates trump
when it comes to his bogus
baseless exhausting tired claims that
actually he won uh georgia and not joe
biden and then trump talking about mike
pillow my pillow ceo mike lindell he
likes him too a patriot a wonderful man
by the way a patriot man who puts his
guts into everything
a man that they don't treat properly
he's smart he loves his country so much
he's willing to die for this country i
watched him over the last week
at his symposium which was really
amazing some of the people do we really
believe trump watched that lunatic
symposium maybe he did i don't know
we're incredible incredible people
mike lindell mike
and the crowd loves it
yeah
so anyway another completely unhinged
rally you know the weird thing we we
stream this live the weird thing about
trump rallies is that the crowd is so
sycophantic i mean at this point they
drive out to the middle of nowhere it's
just a field in alabama thunderstorms
they're there all day waiting for trump
trump's an hour plus late as always
and they just they just love the guy
they love him love him love him and yet
number one he mentions the vaccine and
they boo him and we're going to dig into
that more because i think that's a big
that's a big thing
but also they they very quickly check
out and seem bored at these events it's
this huge huge buildup maybe it's
because they're exhausted by the time
trump actually comes out as soon as
trump comes out to speak they very
quickly lose energy and you see people
on their phones often you see couples
talking to each other and checking the
time you can tell they're talking about
how long are we really going to stay
this is sort of going nowhere it's
almost castro like he's not going six
hours but sometimes going two hours
talking about nothing it's a very weird
thing which shouldn't surprise us
because after all these are the people
we'd expect to see at these events all
right so here's what i have been
building too
with this trump getting booed for
suggesting people get vaccinated at his
alabama rally for months now really
since the 2020 election we've been
talking about how can we deprogram these
trumpists how can we bring tens of
millions of people back to having some
semblance of a connection with reality
and so that they can be meaningful
participants in american society rather
than just people getting in the way that
we have to sort of get around in order
to get anything done and we haven't been
able to figure it out and normally in
history when you look at when there have
been massive shifts in public
consciousness when you look at massive
cultural shifts massive when when things
happen that quickly usually it's because
some dictator has come in and imposed
an authoritarian dictatorial government
one of the greatest examples of this is
the chinese cultural revolution where
you had it wasn't that people's views
just evolved naturally really quickly it
was that you had uh a dictatorial
authoritarian government come in and say
this is the new culture
that is not likely to happen in the
united states so and that's good and so
absent that the question we've been
asking is how do we bring these people
back and i really thought a lot about
this during my trip to europe from which
i came back last week because i was just
in a place without trumpists for a
little bit and it sort of gave me some
context and my feeling is increasingly
these people are too far gone they can't
be brought back now i'm not throwing in
the towel i still think we continue to
talk about it and figure this out but i
do believe that for the most part these
people are too far gone
and then the cherry on top i think was
at the rally saturday night in alabama
where trump says to his own sycophants i
mean there's no greater suck-ups for
trump than the people that spend 12
hours waiting for him at a rally trump
says the vaccine is good go and get it
and then they jeer and they boo i mean
this is the trump that could shoot
people on fifth avenue and not lose his
supporters and he says the vaccine is
good go and get it and they boo and he
immediately has to backtrack i played
this clip in the segment about the rally
but let's just look at it one more time
three days less than nine months and
it's great and you know what i believe
totally in your freedoms i do agree you
got to do what you have to do but
i recommend taking the vaccines i did it
it's good take the vaccines but
you got no that's okay that's all right
you got your freedoms
but i happen to take the vaccine
if it doesn't work you'll be the first
to know okay
i'll call up alabama and say hey you
know what
but it is working
but uh you do have your freedoms you
have to keep you have to maintain that
you have to maintain that and you got to
get your kids back to school
that's sort of like game set match for
me guys i mean i'm i'm ready to declare
it these people are too far gone to be
brought back at the mass scale level now
at some micro level
we regularly hear you know i've been
working on my crazy cousin for for four
months and now they've changed their
mind that can happen but at a mass scale
i don't know that we're bringing these
people back and so trump has really lost
control of his own monster if he can't
control it nobody can i used the analogy
earlier of you get a protection dog and
it's so aggressive it's dangerous even
to the owner it's trying to protect you
lose control of the dog
uh mary shelley's frankenstein is
another you know that these are these
are the thoughts that i'm having and as
i asked earlier i think this is the
correct me if i'm wrong i think this is
the first time a rally crowd has
actually booed something that donald
trump said
and trump really needed to be promoting
the vaccine in a more real way before he
left office between january 6th and
january 20th not as i'm great because i
got us the vaccine and biden will screw
it up but just everybody get it it's
safe it's effective it wasn't really
available while donald trump was still
in office but it's just too late for
that the damage was done
and it shouldn't really surprise us that
now his own crowd boos him when he says
get vaccinated because trump refused to
wear a mask in 2020.
he called it the china virus and a hoax
and trump continued to do all of the
things that would encourage people
ultimately not to get vaccinated and i
don't think we can get him back at this
point in time uh so sanity in the
american right wing returning if we ever
had it is going to depend on young
people who aren't yet political now
hopefully we can pull those people left
but if they end up on the right maybe
they would be
not crazy like these trumpists
non-trump republicans who maybe can grow
their share of the party but i don't
know that these tens of millions of
people can be brought back trump broke
them
and even he can't fix them and that's
really crazy
the vaccine now exists in this other
america
almost like this mark of the beast that
they talk about
and some wrote to me saying david don't
worry about it it's darwinian but it's
it's really not first of all because
many of those people already had kids
um and some of them even brought their
kids to this rally darwinian would be
some trait that's disadvantageous to
reproduction but a lot of these people
have already reproduced and then as far
as the vaccines go as i mentioned
earlier
i suspect one of the most effective ways
to get these people to get vaccinated
would be
you say healthcare companies say
if you are unvaccinated and you need
covid treatment you don't pay a copay
you straight up pay 50
of what it costs and that can be tens of
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
of dollars i think that gets a bunch of
these people to become vaccinated but in
some sense
a lot of this makes perfect sense that
this is the way they would feel at this
point because for the last 18 months
they were told covet's not real
or it's real but it's not serious
we don't need to change anything about
our day-to-day
the vaccines may not work the vaccine is
experimental joe biden will force
vaccinations the vaccine might kill you
it might magnetize you all this
different stuff and now
you know in late august of 2021 trump
says the vaccine is good go and get it
in some sense of course they booed what
happens next i have no idea
if you think these people are not too
far gone
i want to hear from you and tell me
exactly how we bring them back to
reality we'll have more on this on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount join
pacman.com
okay let's talk about a couple of other
happenings over the weekend that are
horrifying and disgusting radical
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
green
has filed articles of impeachment
against joe biden and of course they're
going nowhere and we don't really care
other than there is a really important
thing that's going on here there's a
reason that she's doing this and the
reason is
that it's helping her to raise money and
if you need proof of that just see how
excited this crowd gets when she says i
filed articles of impeachment against
joe biden the crowd seemingly not caring
not knowing not understanding that the
articles will go nowhere this is an
event i don't even know where this took
place it sort of doesn't matter it's
bonkers regardless of where it happened
but
what we do know is that marjorie taylor
green on friday introduced three
articles of impeachment against joe
biden they are meaningless they will go
nowhere but that's what she's talking
about in this clip take a look and just
look if you're listening listen to how
the crowd go goes nuts if you're
watching look at how the crowd gives her
a standing ovation as if this is yeah
they're acting like she's cured cancer
or something like that take a look it's
shameful
and for that reason i want to announce
that i have filed articles
[Applause]
oh
and i did that on behalf of the american
people that's not those are articles of
impeachment for marjorie taylor green
those are articles of impeachment for
the united states of america
so completely cult-like how are we i
mean truly how are we in the same
country as these people this the that
crowd seems
almost like another uh it's a it's
certainly a different culture altogether
i mean people overcome with emotion
out of their minds cheering and standing
and clapping and screaming
over something
completely meaningless who's dumber
right i mean who's more pathetic who's
more disconnected from reality the
person who announces it marjorie taylor
green
or the people
who stand up
and cheer
and go crazy and donate money to her
because of the announcement which they
believe has some actual meaning i i
would make the case it's maybe the
people who are doing the donations that
are really the wacky people not that
marjorie taylor green isn't isn't wacky
the three elements as if it matters as
if you're curious um the three elements
to the impeachment articles are number
one biden's withdrawal of afghanistan
which trump planned
would be a reason to impeach joe biden
number two
illegal immigration through the u.s
mexico border an issue which was
happening under donald trump as well and
lastly
joe biden's eviction moratorium which is
a good thing
marjorie taylor green wants biden
impeached because he extended the
eviction moratorium okay
greene's statement announcing the
impeachment resolution also refers to
joe biden as a pseudo-dictator
and says that he quote shredded the
constitution
it declares his government quote
illegitimate because it is quote no
longer serving its citizens
this is actually all about one thing
like yes marjorie taylor green is cuckoo
for coco puffs she's out of her mind yes
there's no doubt about that
but this is about one thing and that's
fundraising and sadly it helps her
fundraise it does because the people who
donate to her have no idea what's going
on uh in this world in this universe
they uh hear this stuff and they donate
and she did this in the past and it
worked in the past and she's doing it
again now as a brief aside
one other thing about what i call
dumb standing ovations
republican california recall
gubernatorial candidate larry elder he
got a dumb standing ovation for saying
if he becomes the governor of california
he would end vaccine and mask mandates
take a look at this and check out the
crowd i become
governor
assuming
[Music]
i appreciate the optimism
when i become governor assuming there
are still mandates for vaccines and
mandate for face masks they will be
repealed before i hit my first couple
yeah so they they almost
like
making a big deal out of giving a
standing ovation for meaningless just
idiotic or nonsense stuff
um but it works and it sucks money out
of these people one day after joe biden
took office remember marjorie taylor
green filed articles of impeachment
already
you might be wondering well on day one
how what are you even impeached for on
that day
she accused biden of abuse of power
for allowing his son hunter to work for
a ukrainian energy company when he was
vice president and even if you believed
there was something there
it's not something biden did as
president none of it makes sense but
within hours she started sending out
fundraising emails saying look i just
have filed articles of impeachment
donate to me so i can keep doing it and
it worked
completely unable to advance any
legislation
um completely unable to even engage on
policy in a meaningful way i mean what
on what policy is green actually engaged
screaming about mask requirements at the
floor of the house that's it uh so this
is what they've been reduced to now in
all seriousness
there's a really good chance that if
republicans do take control of the house
next year they will impeach biden it
will go nowhere in the senate but they
want to make joe biden impeached
so that it will be just like trump was
impeached they want to weaken they want
to devalue impeachment in total by just
impeaching biden for nothing they will
say
well nancy pelosi started it when she
impeached trump over nothing the
difference is there were grounds to
impeach trump bartering with a foreign
nation and using military aid as
blackmail to get them to make negative
statements about joe biden okay biden
pulled out of afghanistan it was chaotic
it would have been if trump pulled out
but it's actually a major accomplishment
to get us out not something you impeach
a president over but they just want to
make impeachment the norm they want to
take control of the house and they want
to impeach joe biden
to show that joe biden can be an
impeached president as well now just one
last thing on that
if they impeach biden and the senate
were to convict
um then kamala harris is president and
if they impeach kamala harris then nancy
pelosi is president that would be if
they did it now not if they do it after
taking control of the house
so
what exactly is the point of all of this
anyway none of it really makes any sense
it's going to go nowhere but marjorie
taylor green is raising big bucks on the
back of it
there's a new talking point that's
becoming very popular and it has to do
with blaming black people for covid for
low vaccination numbers and why not
right i mean you might as well try if
you're republicans right now and
everything's going wrong try blaming
black people why not
this is texas lieutenant governor dan
patrick he was on fox news's laura
ingraham program he said the reason
kovit is spreading wildly in texas is
black folks black folks who won't get
vaccinated this is the same dan patrick
who earlier in the pandemic said open
everything because we got to do it for
the economy and grandma is willing to
sacrifice herself let's listen to him
explain
uh why
black people are to blame they're coming
after your state really quickly here as
a response coming after your state
because the increase coveted numbers
hospitalizations deaths are up in texas
uh and there's a direct assault on
your governor's policies and your
state's policies very brief response
yeah well laura the the covet is
spreading particularly most of the
numbers are with the unvaccinated and
the democrats like to blame republicans
on that well the biggest group in most
states are african-americans who have
not been vaccinated the last time i
checked over 90 percent of them vote for
democrats in their major cities and
major counties so it's up to the
democrats to get just as it's up to
republicans to try to get as many people
vaccinated but we respect the fact that
if people don't want the vaccination
we're not going to force it on them
that's their individual right but in
terms of criticizing the republicans for
this we're encouraging people who want
to take it to take it but they're doing
nothing for the africa african-american
community that has uh a significant high
number of unbacked tick-tock videos we
got a lot of stuff we got a lot of
tick-tock now
you have to be able to apply some logic
here and what i mean by that is
let's pretend that dan patrick has a
point here at least he could have a
point right it could be that he has a
point
texas only has a 13 black population
so even if a full 50
of black texans don't want to get
vaccinated that's only six and a half
percent of the total population of texas
but we have data about who are the most
anti-vax cohorts of the population and
the most anti-vax group is republicans
roughly 30 percent
it is true that black folks in the
united states as well as people without
college degrees hispanic americans and
some other groups these are some of the
more vaccine hesitant groups that's true
but republicans are the ones that take
the cake here's another data set from
the kaiser family foundation which finds
the most vaccinated groups are democrats
white democrats
65 plus americans college graduates etc
black adults are right in the middle and
republicans and in particular white
republicans are at the very very bottom
and then in the raw numbers 39 of
registered voters in texas are
republicans but only 13 are black people
meanwhile it's 45 percent of the texas
population that hasn't even gotten one
dose and dan patrick wants to blame a
group that's 13 of the population and is
sort of getting vaccinated at roughly
the same rate as the average americans
are now if you want to see an
interesting graphic we'll put up on the
screen now on the left is the map of
vaccination in texas and on the right is
the map of the liberal areas in texas
the more left-leaning areas they match
perfectly the most vaccinated parts of
texas are the most liberal parts of
texas but it's anything they can do to
shift the blame and what they're
choosing now is let's blame black people
it's just perfect actually for them i'm
not surprised that this is what they're
doing
i'm surprised it took them this long to
try it just blame black people why not
and then meanwhile they'll also say
it's people pouring over the border
thanks to joe biden it's illegal
immigrant hispanics that are bringing
the virus the most anti-vaxx groups
are republicans and white republicans
and that's who's driving this at the end
of the day
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right mississippi
is in real trouble when it comes to the
pandemic and they are not messing around
they are now threatening five years in
prison for people who skip covet
isolation
if it involves a life-threatening
situation so let's take a look at what
is going on here covid19 patients must
isolate or face fines
under the new mississippi department of
health order
as covid19 cases across the state
continue to surge
state health leaders are hoping a new
order will encourage people infected to
self-isolate friday state health officer
dr thomas dobbs handed down a mandate
that all individuals vaccinated or not
who test positive must stay home
upon learning they are infected this is
the key part individuals who fail to do
so could be charged with a misdemeanor
punishable by a fine of 500
6 months imprisonment or both upon
conviction and then here's the key key
line
if a life-threatening disease is
involved
failure to follow the order could result
in a fail felony charge
carrying a fine of up to five thousand
dollars five years in prison or both the
news comes as mississippi continues to
report thousands of new infections daily
and as it leads the nation in new cases
per 100 000 inhabitants there are people
saying this is crazy this is too much
but understand what is happening in
mississippi
mississippi at baseline this is
pre-coveted and during it just aside
from covid
mississippi is 50th out of 50
in healthcare rankings in the united
states this includes access cost and
quality okay
mississippi is also the second least
vaccinated state in the country they're
ahead of only alabama
and even then only by half a point
basically mississippi and alabama are
together the two least vaccinated states
in the country
mississippi is out of icu beds as of two
weeks ago
when dr leanne woodward tweeted there
were zero available icu beds in
mississippi as of early this morning
none
that means hospitals across the state
may not be able to provide the level of
care needed to you or your loved one
not just for covid19
but for any emergency care
understand that this affects everybody
this effect put covet aside this affects
vaccinated people who get covered and
unvaccinated people who get covered but
this affects people who just are driving
an activity that is not without risk and
you get into a serious car accident and
you need an icu
and the icu is full
overwhelmingly because of anti-vaxxers
who have covered and are in an icu
uh or whatever it is that leads to you
being at the hospital the hospital will
be full
so yes mississippi is taking this
seriously they're saying you risk five
years in prison if you test positive and
don't isolate now meanwhile by the way
alabama hit negative 11 available icu
beds so
exactly what that means varies minus 11
could mean
they have 11 people who should be in the
icu but there's no room for them and
they're being somehow some other way
accommodated
or it could mean that they have gone
they've basically set up 11
kind of like emergency icu type beds
even though they're not really icu beds
regardless
negative icu availability is a very very
bad thing so that's what's going on in
mississippi that's what's going on in
alabama and increasingly we are seeing
children children hospitalized with the
virus so extremely serious stuff going
on and good for mississippi for doing
something we have kind of an interesting
little wrinkle or sub story in the
january 6 trump riots we know of course
about hundreds of defendants whose cases
are now
somewhere in the legal system and going
through we've started to see some of the
first sentences several weeks ago we saw
some of the first sentences for the
trump rioters who were charged we now
have another prominent individual who
has been charged this is this is
actually quite interesting
many of you remember infowars this is
alex jones conspiracy website um their
content is banned from a number of
different uh mainstream platforms
including youtube i think facebook i
don't remember the whole list i think
they're banned from spotify but the show
continues funding comes from supplements
and i think from mike pillow um and
maybe a couple of other brands you have
to really look pretty hard for the show
but it is out there and one of their
hosts is a guy named owen schroer
he has been charged and reportedly is
turning himself in today
this is a reuters report which says u.s
prosecutors have charged a texas man who
hosts a talk show tied to the conspiracy
theory website infowars with unlawfully
breaching the u.s capitol grounds during
the january 6 riot by supporters of
then-president donald trump owen shroyer
unlawfully entered a restricted area at
the west side of the capitol during the
deadly rampage that interrupted the
formal congressional certification of
biden's victory this is based on what
prosecutors wrote in unsealed court
papers from friday
the host
uh he hosts a talk show associated with
infowars called the war room with owen
shroyer it's a daily show
these are misdemeanor charges violent
entry and disorderly conduct on capitol
grounds
let's look at a video here of owen
schroer explaining this this he learned
this apparently from his lawyer during a
live broadcast on friday take a look at
this the deal
ladies and gentlemen yeah
a couple hours ago
i was informed by my attorney very
serious
that there is a warrant out for my
arrest
with allegations
involving
january 6th
and i will have to turn myself in
monday morning today
uh there's a lot of questions
some i have answers too some i
don't i'm not gonna be getting into more
of this today on the air
smart
and
i plan on
declaring
innocence of these charges
right because i am and so there's some
other stuff going on too
but uh that's the deal
oh boy and so i i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna comment any further on this i'm
not gonna take any questions on this
today
but again the questions thing do they
even take questions on this show like
who's gonna force them to answer
questions on this show and i was
informed by my lawyer that there's a
warrant out for my arrest right now and
that i have to turn myself in by
monday morning
so
uh that's just that
probably shouldn't even be on air right
now but we're gonna go ahead and do a
broadcast anyway
okay and that's probably the correct
instinct he probably should not be on
the air uh if this is if this is what is
going on so there's owen schroer another
uh relatively high profile
target of the investigation has turned
up multiple alleged charges against him
and will follow it these are misdemeanor
charges it is less likely he will do
prison time it is more likely he has
better access to lawyers particularly if
alex jones is going to help him out but
owen schroer
uh turning himself in as far as he is
saying he will do
today
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p here's a sad voicemail
this is a supposed progressive who's
canceling me he's saying he's
unsubscribing
because i refuse to lie to him this
viewer
wants me to lie to him and because i
won't
he's unsubscribing take a listen to this
this is very sad very very sad
david i think you're very smart
uh honest
and i agree with you most of the time
but i just had to unsubscribe and stop
listening because you are normalizing
trump's criminal behavior
and trump's crimes every time you say
trump will never be indicted
for a felony or never
you know go to jail or prison for a
felony that's normalizing what he does
and no no no no
it's telling the truth
it's telling the truth trump's not going
to go to prison for anything he did
while president he's not going to i'm
not going to lie to you it's not
progressive to lie to you and
you're just too intelligent for that and
it really angers me
wow and i i'm
my political perspective is i am a
very progressive democrat
that's fine but why would you want me to
lie to you then
um
i really think you should rethink
telling your
viewers that that trump will never be
indicted or never go to prison well
there's really nothing to rethink the
question is
what do i think he will go to prison and
remember i never said he wouldn't be
indicted i said trump is not going to
see the inside of a jail cell or a
prison cell that's what i said i believe
that's the truth i don't lie to people
on this show i don't tell people things
because it's what they want to hear i'm
not going to give you false hope
it's conceivable that trump's business
will be sanctioned it's conceivable that
some of the people around trump will be
indicted it's i guess conceivable trump
might be indicted but trump isn't going
to prison and i am not going to fuel
people in my audience
imagining that we're going to see trump
in an orange jumpsuit
in cuffs because we're not going to see
it and so if you're looking for a show
that will
tell you things that are untrue
there's many of them available but
that's not the way i do things on this
program it's just a fantasy
it's not progressive
to say things that aren't true
because progressives would like to see
those things happen i would be doing
everybody a disservice if i did that so
the complaint is i'm not willing to lie
to you guys and you know what
guilty is charged i'm going to tell you
things the way i see them we've got a
great bonus show for you today
california has launched an investigation
into larry elder
larry elder's financial disclosure larry
elder is running for the california
gubernatorial recall election we'll talk
about that
nasa would like to get back to the moon
by 2024 unfortunately the new generation
space suits won't be ready and this may
end up being uh the first and
potentially many
delays with getting back to the moon by
2024 and we will talk about a new report
very disturbing and important report
that facebook's most viewed article in
early 2021
was one casting doubt on the covet
vaccine
and the degree to which facebook is tied
in with the uncontrolled spread of
misinformation disinformation and
conspiracy theories is horrifying quite
frankly so we're going to look at all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show make sure you get instant access by
signing up at
joinpackman.com if you'd rather do it
via patreon we are on patreon as well
and you can find us at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we have a
fantastic week for you this week we've
got great interviews we're going to try
a slightly different format
for the friday show and so many things
going on it's great to be back and we
will see you in mere moments on the
bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors ground news is
combating divisiveness in media ground
is a news comparison platform that helps
you see multiple perspectives for any
news story so you can be more of a
well-rounded news reader download the
free app at
news slash pacman